hello and welcome to our first ever
murder
mystery moon this is a bonus episode
and halloween is coming up yes and we
thought that you might enjoy
some very spooky scary tales
that are true stories
but first booze so oh yeah murder
mystery booze
yes today we made a blackberry bramble
and
this is like a simple version of it we
used
two ounces of gin i like kendricks but
you can use whatever you want an ounce
of simple syrup which you can make
by boiling sugar and water together 50
50 of each
the juice of half a lemon and topped it
off with some ginger ale
what you're going to want to do is put
all the gin the simple syrup the lemon
all your blackberries oh yeah you want
blackberries too
i forgot to mention you want
blackberries in the blackberry ramble
you muddle those up into a shaker
you shake them you put it into a glass
over ice
and fill the rest up with some ginger
ale and then
garnish with some blackberries and there
you go you got a blackberry bramble
this is very delicious cheers ladies hey
cheers so our first
murder mystery maker murder mr moon
triple m
drunk detective because when i get drunk
i think i could solve crimes
this is one that has really stuck with
me ever since i first heard it
i have not been able to let it go it's
just like a really
special one so i'm going to tell you the
way it was told to me
in the beginning scared it's very
very since then new evidence has come
out but this is how the story goes
so downtown los angeles there was a
location over here
i used to live in downtown los angeles
oh there were hoes walking around oh my
god
one name was just caldwell there was a
hotel
in downtown los angeles there's still a
hotel there there's a few different
names
there's just a this one is called
the hotel cecil you heard of it yes yes
wait is this the one where they like the
american horror story
yes series was based on i [ __ ] loved
that season and by the way i didn't
watch that season it's so good after
watching
is this based off a true story this is a
true story oh god yes
so 21 year old elisa lam she's a
canadian
vietnamese let's go girl she uh was in
college
um in british columbia and she was like
you know what
i want to be spontaneous and explore
different parts of the world travel
she's never
really got out of her house before you
know never really moved away from home
and so she got the itch to go explore
and she would write on tumblr a lot
about
um wanting to meet new people and
adventure out and so one day she was
like you know what i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna go to california and i'm gonna
tour southern california oh yeah girl
get my feet wet out there california
dreaming baby yes
yes california dream so she went to san
diego first she spent some days there
had some fun she was really feeling it
she alone she was alone
yeah she was like in bora bora but
in san diego so then she uh took the
amtrak to los
angeles and she was her first mistake
sorry i know
she comes to los angeles and i don't
know why she decides to check into hotel
cecil because
if you know this area of downtown it's
like right next to skid row
it's a very very seedy area and this was
in 2013 so this was january 26
2013. wait run down dude
i'm getting into numbers here so january
26 2013
yes 26 divided by two is like 213s and
then 2013.
there's a lot of 13s going on there's a
lot of crazy [ __ ] like that and then
anyway sorry go ahead she likes math
everybody
yeah that's so hot math she originally
checked in and was staying in like a
hostel style room oh no with other
roommates that she had in that hotel
they did
yeah back in 2013. it's now called the
stay on main and i think they try to do
a rebrand
oh they changed it yeah oh thanks for
telling me i will never stay there
right oh so she was she was supposed to
stay there for a few days she was
originally
checked into a hostel style room but
then she had to be moved because
her roommates complained of her having
like really odd behavior
so they're kind of freaked out by her
and so they moved her to a private room
then she is that all i gotta do tonight
up to a private room because
[ __ ] will start talking to walls if i
have to okay
just stand in the corner so she gets
moved and then the last time
anyone saw her was february well january
31st she was supposed to check out on
february
backwards no god she didn't check out
she was
nobody heard from her her family didn't
hear from her and she had been calling
her family every day
for like the whole time she was away so
it was really odd that she
didn't check in with them and her cell
phone's never been found
what yeah and these are vietnamese
parents they will call you the moment
you step out of your house to ask you
where the [ __ ] you are
so she goes missing right and so her
family thinks it's really weird that
she's not checking in so they file a
missing person's report
and um canada from canada yeah okay and
then um
a week later the lapd um releases a
statement and they're like
yo we searched the entire hotel with
with canine
dogs and everything they we couldn't
find her we don't know where she is
we're about cctv footage well we'll get
there
so then they ended up finding her body a
week later
and this was well a little over a week
later it was february
later maybe two weeks and one day
later february 19th it was 18 days
after her body was reported missing so
18 days later it was february 19th they
found
her body on in a water tank on top of
the roof oh
wait a water tank in a water in a four
foot by eight foot water tank what's the
water tank's purpose
to serve to provide water food water for
the hotel
and the reason she was found the way she
was found
was because there were complaints from
hotel guests that they would turn on the
faucet and the water would run sludgy
black
for a few minutes before returning to
its normal color no way
yeah her body was decomposing after only
18 days and
it was too over yeah yeah oh my gosh
imagine being a resident like a hotel
guest
and then finding out later you were dead
bodies and
brushing your teeth with dead body water
oh that's crazy
oh yeah are people who drink out of the
faucet also
never drink out of a hotel hotel guests
were brushing their teeth with the water
they were also um one couple was from
visiting from england and they didn't
say anything about the water because
they thought that was just standard for
l.a
well you know what i don't call it them
i get it yeah so they found her body
with
in the water tower as she was naked with
her clothes in the water
and the lid was on the water tower which
people thought was strange because
she was only 115 pound girl she was a
small
person um she would have had to climb
first of all there was no access to the
roof
so um the only access to the roof was
either she climbs up these crazy fire
escapes
or she goes through this door that has
an alarm on it and you can only get
through it
if you have a badge that gets you
through an outside job
alarm would get set off right so maybe
um but then she would have had to climb
up a 10-foot ladder to get up onto the
water tower
then she would have had to remove this
lid which looked really hard to remove
when fire
when the firefighters were trying to
remove it to remove her body
um and then she would have had to go in
there with nothing there's no foot rest
or any ladder to get in
and then somehow on robe and also get
the lid back
over her so people were kind of like
how how did that happen yeah so this is
with the footage that they released from
lapd this is the last time that she was
seen in the elevator in the elevator who
you saw it to
show you oh i'm creeped out hold on here
that's just tiny windows
okay so this was the last footage this
is the footage that everybody reacts to
and is that the same why is she bending
over like that
is she wearing very close that they
found her yes or well that were next to
her
yeah did she press all the buttons yeah
she pressed all the buttons
oh she's on something oh this is creepy
oh my gosh i'm creeped out
oh this is like a this is like a [ __ ]
asian horror film what the [ __ ]
i've seen this footage but it feels
brand new what is she doing
oh why is she who's she hiding from or
something
it's like she's playing a game like with
a friend or something though or like a
little kid you know
why won't the elevator go yeah why isn't
the elevator going
well i'll tell you
first watch this it's still not even
like trying to close in on her not
at all what the [ __ ]
do we know what floor this was she's
like playing looks like she's playing
with a kid
right like that's how i'd play with like
my knees
she's playing peekaboo get the way she's
stepping too it's like very
like square yeah like right angles she's
making right angles with her steps
[Music]
why is this the only camera angle they
have like there's nothing else
when i used to work in hotels there were
cameras in every hallway
people brought this up no way
oh did she press the um like the butt
she goes and pushes all the buttons
again
like the you know when you press the the
elevator service one
no like the the fire one like it'll just
stop the whole elevator
she exited as well so people were first
the [ __ ] is she thinking
she's doing it in a like a specific
pattern yeah a specific pattern
and using both hands this is a
schizophrenic break
it kind of looks like she's losing it
so look at her hands oh people think
this oh what the [ __ ]
creepy what the [ __ ] what just happened
because the way her hands move people
are saying that's really unnatural the
way she's moving her hands
i'm kind of so scary she can't like how
she do that
and it looks like she's talking to
somebody honestly a lot of people on
skid row kind of look like this though
so
she scored something looks like someone
yeah whatever like bath salts
like she was down on like eighth and
[ __ ] flower or something what if she
was so
adventurous that her hostile friend's
like hey try these drugs and she did
and then she od'd and then they they hit
they hit her body
because if she was like just on skid row
i would i wouldn't feel like this was
not normal but because she's in a hotel
the rest of this footage is just like
empty elevator but then the elevator
finally closes after all that time
that's another thing is that like people
were wondering why did you release all
this extra footage of just the empty
elevator like what purpose did that
serve
well she pressed all the buttons right
so it's probably just going to differ
yeah so people were asking like why
didn't the elevator close
and she actually in that particular
hotel because there were a lot of
residents that
lived there they had installed they have
a elevator hold button
that once you press it um it holds the
door open for two minutes so that if
you're moving furniture in
yeah so that answered that question
another thing that they
mentioned is that um uh she
was actually bipolar and so she was on
four different medications
but she was on her medications so in her
toxicology report she
had been taking her medications although
maybe not to a tee
the way that they're supposed to be
taken she was still taking them
in the proper amounts um but bipolar
people don't act
crazy like that it's more of like an
emotional thing
so people were trying to just put a pin
in it they ruled her death an accidental
death
because uh they were like well she she's
bipolar
look at this footage she's acting very
strange her roommates complained and
that's why she had to be moved
and she looks like she just had an
episode
wandered up to the roof somehow got in
the water tower
and accidentally drowned so it was ruled
an accident
how did she close the thingy on herself
like
what yeah exactly how did she just end
up on the water
so there were a couple theories that
came out right away one
was that she was on drugs or
hallucinogens well that's what it looks
like to me yeah
right so clean the hand well
when they did the autopsy though there
were there were no reports
they did the toxicology report and there
were no drugs
in her system but she was like boiling
in a water tower so do you think that
toxicology would be effective
maybe body boiling in a water towel it
was boiling
i mean i imagine it was on the roof and
it's metal and it's hot
the sun is beating down on a metal water
it could be very january it is january
yeah that's true
and the metal and uv rays in january on
a ceiling i forget what 2013
it's much closer to the ozone layer i'm
surprised i mean i thought you'd know i
know right
she's in water was that a hot year that
was the year stephen i got together
she was in water so her body would be
badly badly decomposed depending on how
long it was in there so
maybe the toxic well no i mean they're
professionals the [ __ ] am i doing
questioning their work
yeah i don't know about that well i
don't know i thought the cops would be
professionals but
she could have think about the whole
like closing the lid
in on her so how close was the elevator
footage to her actual
being found it was like 20 days later
that was the night before
oh so not being found um this was the
night before
she died so they by based on her autopsy
she had been sitting up there
since she was missing whoa still over
24 hours no so she
what are you talking about how long is
it between this elevator footage
and when they found her when they found
her body like from
february first to february 19th so yeah
so she probably could have been on drugs
in this video but just
like more time went by she was missing
maybe she got held in a room by some
creeper the drugs left her body maybe
you know
she got kidnapped because she was on
drugs and then
they came out of her system and then so
they found her so this she could have
still been on drugs in this video
i don't really know how toxicology
reports work but they were pretty
confident that she wasn't on any drugs
or alcohol
or the question well in the video she
could have been because that was 18 days
prior to her actually being found
yeah i don't know how yeah part of the
mystery maybe
yes you could be right the question is
how long after this footage
which was she killed or died did she die
do you
know the night this was the same night
the same night she passed away
yes she was found in those same clothes
she was in the water for 18 days yes
jesus
um but so she so a couple theories
one was that she was on drugs and had a
psychotic break but a lot of
psychologists were like
well it doesn't look like a manic
episode
um and even if it was that would more
likely make her a target
of a predator then um for her to just go
and like climb a bunch of ladders and
have super strength and
remove a lid right so then the second
theory is murder like maybe she was
murdered by somebody maybe it was inside
job like you were talking about before
people were like how can there be no
other videos
of this of this girl like usually
there's
footage from the entire hotel um
there were also like people were
noticing that the
footage seemed edited really yeah like
there's a minute missing
from it and so the hotel said well
we were trying to cut around um guests
that were there because we didn't want
to reveal their identities
they can blur that [ __ ] yeah but in a
whole last minute
yeah and why did the lapd like say that
when they're releasing the footage
so it kind of seems like they're hiding
something maybe they release the footage
to
give people the narrative which just
crazy yeah
just so they could like they found the
crazy footage of her
exactly but i bet the hotel owner or
whoever security someone's watching this
footage right and they see this girl
being weird over like the course of
january and they're like oh i'm gonna
murder this one
maybe and so they only kept the footage
of her being weird to release to the
police
it's the security guard what's his
backstory they want to protect
what if it's someone more powerful than
that that actually is behind this and
then he paid the owner
i feel like or even more powerful oh
like yeah some big
something big shot la producer yeah
harvey weinstein did it
yeah right harvey weinstein oh no she's
too old for him he'd like some little
and i don't think he would go to cd
hotel season that's exactly where he
would go
he would have her come to him true
in the beverly hills hotel oh wow so the
third theory
and this one's a little more sketchy but
it was ghosts
people think that maybe she got
possessed maybe she got possessed to go
uh climb up on the water tower and take
her life
um it looks like she's talking to
someone people are like how come there's
no one there
you know it looks like she's talking to
someone and also there's this second
video and i don't know why
nobody's talking about this i found it
on some random youtube channel
and i don't see it anywhere else on the
internet and no one else is talking
about it i don't know if it's like a
fake thing but are you gonna get us
killed
listen by making this is like the ring
okay
is this scary check out the second
footage this is scary i'm scared
is it edited so no this is a different
she goes back in the hotel oh
oh gosh she's so scary looking
oh scary no i could because i've seen so
many asian scary movies i'm like nope
no thanks that look on her face gave me
chills yeah
oh no no what she's standing in the oh
she's so weird
why she's so weird oh man that was
really scary what's going to happen is
there a jump scared
no there's no jump scare what is she
doing she put her her head
she's like has her head in her hands
oh
[Music]
with her hair over her face is she's
like the ring girl
is this confirmed i don't know i've only
seen it on
this because this is easily done like it
could be like
re you remade how would you remake this
oh my gosh
oh my gosh she's creepy nikki are you
showing me the ring video right now
she's going to come for us in seven days
because i'm looking away you know
nobody's talked about this video but
if you were to go down that ghost
through line if you saw this video i
could maybe
understand it because why are these
black letters covering the white that's
exactly how it was
when they released it it's okay okay
okay i'm not looking at it i didn't i
didn't want to look at her face because
i'm already freaked out
i'm not looking at it choking her that's
what it looks like right
but there's no one there okay i can't
even look at it i'm already creeped out
i'm not looking
okay she's on her tippy toes so
something's like pulling her up
okay if she's acting like this she's not
before
she needs an oscar this is crazy
that does seem more schizophrenic than
bipolar
you know
oh gosh she's so creepy
the lighting in there so bad it's scary
i know
so i mean that was the scariest part but
other theories were that she played
the elevator game have you heard of the
elevator game what is that so the
elevator ritual and we'll get into like
a ritual
episode later but it's a game that they
started playing in i think it started in
either korea or japan i can't remember
but
um basically you go into an elevator you
have to be alone you press
the buttons in a series of order oh so
yeah she's doing that for sure and then
what happens is when you get to the
fifth floor a woman supposedly walks in
and she's from another world and you're
not supposed to look at her or
acknowledge her or talk to her at all
otherwise you get taken by her to the
other world
and after it's over you're stuck in the
other world forever
and so so why why
so people are what do you mean why why
would people play this game
that's like bloody you don't know yeah
it's like bloody mary it's like why
would you play this game some people are
like i don't think it exists but
there's a system of buttons you have to
practice she was doing
yeah it definitely is what looks what it
what she was doing it looks like what
she was doing
it actually spurred this whole um
spree of people playing the elevator
game after this came out
okay a girl dies they're like hey let's
play this game yeah they're like i want
to see if it's real
i want to die too because okay then the
herd it's fine you can get back
if you do it correctly if you don't
acknowledge the woman that gets on at
the fifth floor
you go to the tenth floor which is the
other world
and you can get out and explore as long
as you don't acknowledge her we love to
eat in this house do we not
yeah yeah we really like to put a lot of
effort into cooking in this house
well you know who helps with that is
hellofresh if you follow me on instagram
you've seen me post a few meals
um i have actually found my new favorite
it's this pork that comes with this like
cherry sauce
cherry balsamic no it's not balsamic
it's a different recipe there's there's
a few similar ones but this one yes yeah
you try to guess
this one is actually you were wrong you
were wrong yeah this one
this one is like this one's like a
different version of that but this one's
a little bit more updated it has like
some cinnamon and like some other
flavors in it so it's like cherry
cinnamon it's like fall
it's like yes it's like a fall version
of that cherry that that pork dish that
we love anyways i love that one
um i like the spaghetti bolognese that
they send because i never knew to put
sour cream in the tomato sauce yeah and
some of the pasta
water into the pasta salt like i'm
learning basic [ __ ] about cooking which
is what makes hellofresh
really cool and fun if you guys want to
try it i think you should
i think you really should you should go
to hellofresh.com 80 big mood and use
code 80 big mood
to get a total of eighty dollars off of
five boxes
how many doll hairs that's 80 doll hairs
across
five boxes which is like maybe your
first month-ish or so
um including free shipping on the first
box so go to hellofresh.com
80 big mood and use code 80 big moo to
get a total of eighty dollars off across
five boxes including free shipping on
your first
box that's 16 hairs per box that's a
little oh thank you for math
yeah i love that she loves math she's
smart that's quite that's quite a
significant amount of doll hairs that we
have going on here
one thing i really like to do in my
spare time is learn new skills
i love reading i like books i like math
so i was perfect for signing up for
skillshare and i can 100
say i love it um it has all sorts of
different topics so no matter what your
interests are you can find a skill share
video that
you can pick up skills that you are
passionate about in i can't decide which
one i'm most passionate about but i did
do a productivity master class
called principles and tools to boost
your productivity taught by ellie abdall
and i have been very productive after
thank you very much
um i also want to take this graphic
design one because um
like i can i can mess around with
photoshop like i'm okay at it
but i'm not like very good good at it
we're to the point where like i don't
feel confident
in like anything that i create to like
put on something
unless i'm like making fun of myself
yeah i need some new merch so get on
that
yes we need to get on that so i'm gonna
pick up some skills in graphic design
maybe
maybe next and you and you have like
actual graphic designers teaching it to
you
and so people that are skilled in that
area maybe you have a skill you would
like to share with others you can also
upload your videos onto skillshare too
which is great um and skillshare offers
membership with meaning there's so much
to explore real projects to create and
the support of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
and it's incredibly affordable
especially when you compare it to like
pricey in-person classes and workshops
an annual subscription
is less than ten dollars per month what
that's not very many doll hairs oh it's
not at all it's like free education
exactly it's like what do you like an uh
a mobile game app costs
more than that yeah but this time you're
learning so
for a limited time get a free trial of
skillshare premium
membership at skillshare.com big mood
girls
receive free access to thousands of
classes for a limited time
and you can explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
big mood girls and get a free trial of
skillshare premium
membership not some basic ass [ __ ] it's
a premium
membership we only give you the premiums
that's right be one of the first
thousand to sign up at skillshare.com
big mood girls hurry big mood girls
you can get out and explore and then you
can get back to the real world
by taking the same elevator and doing
the same exact order of buttons
the same exact sequence and then you're
back to the real world you know what
this kind of reminds me of remember when
i told you guys that when i was little
and that one time i couldn't get the
words out and i was trying to say that i
would
touch tiles in the bathroom a certain oh
no
like in a certain sequence and i would
feel like if i did it in a certain
sequence then i could go into a
different place
you telling me this right now is
creeping me out i'm like what did
three-year-old tiff know what if you are
in the new world
what is this this is the other world i
believe your twins body is your body
right
oh [ __ ] honestly not a bad world because
you have us so yeah
this is probably a blessing a pretty
damn good world yeah
thank you maybe maybe you guys are in my
world yeah
maybe you time travel doing that maybe
you are now
so creeped out we'll talk about the
elevator game more in a different
episode
but that is the third theory that people
had
it was also crazy because um people
thought like she might have been
possessed because
this hotel in particular had a
bunch of several different serial
killers lived there while they were
doing their
killings really right so they kill in
this hotel too
yes yeah how is this hot hotel still
standing dude i don't care if you can
change the name so they thought maybe
she encountered the ghost of
serial killer richard ramirez who was a
night stalker yeah because he lived
there
during that time my dad served time with
him oh my gosh
really so my dad served time in max with
uh richard ramirez and charles manson
whoa he went to a celebrity
prison right um so and then well you
guys have seen my dad and i've spoken
about him a lot of times like my dad
nothing really bothers my dad he's a
very like
macho dude like you know the life that
he's had but he told me
whenever they need to transport ramirez
or manson from like one ward to another
or whatever or any transportation
whatsoever
they would actually shut down the whole
prison everyone has to go back you know
all the doors lock and it's
only them moving across i imagine them
wheeling them out and that like you know
this that mask that yeah what was that
movie
hannibal silence of the lambs
yeah like a meat slab yeah um so my dad
is probably like this the bravest
dopest person i know but he said that
whenever they walk
past his cell there was my dad would get
shivers and he still gets shivers
talking about it they were like evil
yeah he said he said that when you look
in their eyes there's just some
it's not right not right ramirez was
also a known satanist and there were
also
known satanists that stayed in this
hotel along with him
yeah and uh this hotel got super
so famous for the amount of suicides
that would happen so many people
would jump off the roof every year or
not the roof but like out of their
windows
every year that so much so that the
residents started calling it the suicide
hotel
and someone had died in every single
room of this hotel 600 rooms 600
rooms the hell the devil's playing
ground or something
say that again someone died in every
single room every single room
that's what the hotel is still standing
yeah seriously
yeah it's built
a long time ago also it was one of the
last places the black dalio was seen
oh that's a good one yeah whoa
yeah i love that american horror story
season
and favorites i know me too because the
lady gaga is my favorite
i was her for halloween a couple years
ago anyway so ultimately her death was
rolled in accidental
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] right and the
family hotel i'm
i'm putting this on them they were
pissed the family was no no no no no
they
uh they sued them they filed a lawsuit
they're like this was not an
accidental thing but it got ruled out of
court like they lost
so right currently her death is still
ruled an accidental drowning who was the
pew
you are already creeped out there are
even creepier coincidences surrounding
this case
okay one being that in 2002 so remember
this happened in 2013.
well in 2002 a japanese horror movie
came out what is up with these asians i
know right
called dark water and in it the
daughter's name
is cecil i mean cecilia
very close to the cecil hotel cecil
um right so that's a coincidence and
then uh in the movie they end up staying
at this apartment building
name is cecilia kill her
very good disowner she might be
connected too there's some holy water on
that [ __ ]
random fact and the chinese people
rarely name their kids cecilia because
sisila means
die die oh sorry [ __ ] [ __ ] fast sorry
about that
very different things yeah sorry they're
terrible
but also very bad yeah yeah wait that's
not the weirdest part
okay so in the movie the daughter's name
is cecilia
and in the movie they stay at this
apartment building where a murder
happens
where the victim is found in a water
tower on top of the building
and the way that she's found is because
people complained of the water
coming out black saying whoever it is so
whoever killed this girl loved that
moment
11 years later it was everything
happened in 2005
the american version was remade in 2005
and
not only is the daughter named cecilia
but the mother's name is dahlia
what excuse me right and let me show you
hold on let me show you a screen cap
from the original movie
show me girl i moved the video if it's
an elevator scene i'ma lose my [ __ ]
because that means there's someone out
there that's planning all this and he's
still getting away with it no way okay
wearing the same outfit she's wearing
the
same outfit maybe she was obsessed with
this movie and she wanted to die that
way
yeah and she wanted to go down in
history someone killed herself then
maybe she's really good at it she could
have gotten in there i guess
but like for her to like die this plan
this whole trip
and she was cause she wanted to die in
la at this [ __ ] hotel
this famous hotel you think she took her
life maybe now i do because
if it's exactly like all like this movie
she's wearing the same clothes
she's acting crazy she's doing the
[ __ ] asian [ __ ] ritual
that everyone knows about apparently
maybe she wanted to die
famous yeah people are crazy like like
the black dolly's name is like
everyone knows about her right because
she like died in l.a like in a super
weird way
she just wants to be infamous she's
definitely famous now yeah so maybe she
could we know if she had anything else
planned for the rest of her she
definitely did she was going to
tour all of southern california and she
had a tumbler
uh listing things but let's get into
more coincidences
because this gets kind of nuts so um
around the time of elise so glad that
we're all sleeping together tonight
because i'm terrified already and we
still
i'm not terrified because i feel like
she did it also in the movie there are
different scenes
involving the characters that the
footage is surveillance footage from the
elevator
that's the scene okay yes the movie
whatever it is it's involved with
the same angle yeah yeah the movie's
involved so
she's obsessed with the movie she's
obsessed with whoever killed her is
obsessed with that movie they're
reenacting each scene but she her acting
all crazy in the in the elevator herself
it's almost like
she knew they were gonna find the
footage and she wanted to be weird
how would she know that that's how they
were gonna show it with the elevator
directly at the camera too she looked at
the camera she's like when i'm dead
they're gonna
they're gonna look through all the
surveillance footage and they're gonna
release it if that vid second video is
real because that's not the one everyone
talks about everyone talks about that
first video i've never even seen that
second video until i was doing like
crazy research into this so i go back
and forth but
let's go into another coincidence that
happened so during the time of her death
there was the largest outbreak of
tuberculosis in the
in over a decade in los angeles really
i don't remember i gave her a pass it's
okay it's okay it's okay so um that's
not a coincidence that's not a
coincidence so the
the weird thing is uh it affected
thousands of people in downtown l.a
close to the cecil hotel right right
there oh though
um and the medical examiners tested
elisa for the disease by performing a
test
called lamb elisa literally spelled her
like her name
name it's an acronym for this crazy
medical term
lipo
i'm going to put it on the screen but um
it found it out
basically it's an acronym that spells
out lamb
elisa her name
too like elisa is part of the yes what
yeah the second part is
enzyme-linked immunoabsorbent assay
weird so it spells out elisa and it's
developed at oh and it's developed by
scientists
at the university of british columbia
the same university
that she attended weird right is her
name really that glitch
our name really yeah it's really that
this is something deeper like the powers
that be
like they're they're they set this whole
entire thing up there's some [ __ ]
illuminati [ __ ] going on okay here's a
third coincidence that's right
okay when the firefighters removed
elise's body from the rooftop
the pictures showed graffiti on the roof
shot there was pictures
and there was graffiti on the rooftop
and included the latin phrase
fecto [ __ ] her suma which
translates latin
it's a latin phrase that translates to
in fact she was a [ __ ]
it's the best [ __ ] and that's got
nothing to do with no no listen
so in latin the word [ __ ] is
i guess they didn't have the word [ __ ]
on february 1st the date of her
disappearance
she posted this on her tumblr account
quote
[ __ ] again it's odd how men used that
word to
demean women when it was the only part
of a woman they valued
what she did this herself dude she did
it she did you did the
wait do they know who did the graffiti
though no she did it
and they're like how did that person
have access to the rooftop no she did it
while she was up there she was that
[ __ ] was up there for 20 days
don't call her that she's that girl i'm
sorry that girl
was up was up there for 20 days just
probably playing around
she thinks that she was up there smoking
weed she was like oh i'm gonna die like
a famous ass [ __ ] she was doing
graffiti
no one was gonna fight i don't know i
don't know okay here's another here's
the last question did they do
a half-life radiation test on that paint
to see how old it was
they i don't know i don't think they
examined the paint they should but
they should have handwriting everything
did it herself all the evidence
before the drink was very strong
[Applause]
okay please do i'm sure a lot of people
out there would like that
um okay this coincidence is freaking
weird too
so the books so before she died she was
last seen
like one of the last people that talked
to her was a manager at a bookstore that
she bought books from
and the man was it the one downtown the
really cute one yeah the one with the
circle thingy what is it
it's called the last the last bookstore
yeah she was there
she was there she bought some gifts for
her stuff family she bought some albums
she bought some books and she was
talking to the manager and she was like
kind of asking for recommendations
and the manager has described her as
being bright and bubbly and
does he remember her she's been meeting
so many people because
so that bookstore is famous like there's
so many people in and out of that yeah
when there was another person she talked
to in there that described her as being
really friendly but he kind of got
creeped out by how
how much she was sharing she was kind of
eager to talk to people
she wanted to be remembered maybe but
get this
so that was the one of the last places
she was seen one it's called the last
bookstore
pretty weird yeah two um someone looked
up
who owns the who is the registrar for
the domain name that they're registered
under
and it's registered to a po box
that is located in this small well
hold on the registrant management
company that manages their website has
their po box listed in burnaby
which is a suburb in vancouver where
alisa lived and if you look on google
maps
it's located within the forest lawn
cemetery
where elisa is buried current whoa
the p.o box is located in the cemetery
if you look on google maps you type in
that address stop giving me changes
the domain name to the last bookstore's
website
the yeah the regis the registrant
management company that manages their
website
is why is their address is located
in this tiny suburb in vancouver
canada inside the cemetery where she's
buried
uh it's a chain of of cemeteries you
know we have this
one and there's one and there's one in
like burbank too i think
have they questioned these like why do
you have your p.o box in a cemetery
right oh my god what if her whole
existence was for this
like her parents and everything there
she was born to fulfill this
and it started from she was maybe the
wilderness like she was feeling messages
and she was kind of guided
here or something i don't know i don't
believe it i believe it okay
here is some new evidence that was
uncovered that
new evidence changes the story a little
bit okay okay
okay so according to the person that
found her
originally his name was santiago lopez
and according to
the hotel worker he's a hotel worker
he's head of maintenance at the hotel
he's worked there for a long time hard
work he loves
we love him his sworn testimony
is that on the alarm on the rooftop was
working but according to the hotel gm
amy price the alarm was not activated
between january and february
which contradicts the hotel's original
statement that the rooftop wasn't
accessible so they're saying anybody
could have gone up there
how did they know that it wasn't working
um that's what the
hotel manager said so she just knew
that they had turned off their alarm
yeah during that time
but for what reason hmm like why was the
alarm off we don't know we don't know
that's
uh suspect yeah which would help would
have helped the family
maybe win their wrongful death long
lawsuit because they didn't protect the
roof from
yeah why is this new information
santiago right well no santiago's
testimony is that the
rooftop was working we'd love santiago
and then amy price later
says no it wasn't working wait what the
[ __ ] gave me price
yeah [ __ ] amy price then a youtuber um
actually
went to la and filmed himself going to
the cecil hotel and records his steps
to access the rooftop and was able to
get there no problem the alarm didn't go
off or anything so they just like never
have the alarm on
maybe not they're full of [ __ ] and they
just say they have an alarm so i'm going
back to what the [ __ ] santiago and then
when santiago gave it to
you said the lid was open meaning like
maybe she could have fallen in
and uh the firefighter then when andrew
smith
one of the first officers on the scene
um was talking about he said the lid was
closed but
how could she close it on herself after
climbing into the tank with no foot
right now oh
santiago wait but or the cops okay then
shortly after santiago gave his sworn
testimony he was paid a large sum of
money to move from la to mexico
the source is his half-brother domike
lopez
who didn't know that he left town until
much later he's like that [ __ ]
give me any money
and this is a guy that's that his whole
livelihood has been here he's been
working here for 30 years yeah why would
he
leave and then all of a sudden his
brother paid him to move no no the
brother didn't pay him
he was paid out a large we don't know we
don't know but his mother his brother
was like that [ __ ] got money and
skipped
he was paid a large sum of money to move
to mexico if
okay if santiago was paid to move away
let's
say he was in on it right why would he
lie and say that the
the lid was open when the cops got there
it was closed so it helps the case that
there's not a wrongful
death lawsuit because it was open
meaning
she she fell in there or went in there
on her own so my question is
let's say you're gonna go with the fact
that it was open
why wouldn't you leave it open why would
it be closed when people get there
i don't know maybe they told them to say
that later like
maybe they were like hey whatever you
saw
say this instead you know we don't know
yeah if someone's like
if someone's telling if someone's
telling someone to change the story
obviously
the first cop at the scene would be like
oh no it's closed he's like reporting
[ __ ] in or writing stuff on his notes
but then
once the cover-up story comes in it's
like too late and like we heard one
thing
yeah there's more pay uh payout
allegations too
so the day after elise's body was found
the hotel closed a large deal with cbre
which is one of the largest real estate
firms
in the world i recognize that logo i've
seen that yeah
yeah so some wondered if maybe that was
the reason they delayed in finding her
body because they didn't want to ruin
the deal
oh yeah and then there's this
there's an investigative journalist who
wrote a book his name is jake anderson
and he wrote a book called gone at
midnight
and he was basically obsessed with this
case when it first came out because it's
like
there are so many unanswered questions a
lot of people were just really like
there's so much that wasn't revealed so
he spent a lot of time at the cecil
hotel he interviewed tons of
employees people that lived there
residents people who
live around the area like just spent a
lot of time there digging and
interviewing police officers and
deputies anyone that was involved in the
case
and he basically
had people reach out to him and there
was this one girl named tanya danielle
who was a hotel guest
and she said that she was assigned to a
room on a floor that nobody was on
and a hotel employee offered to give her
a tour of the hotel
and that he was like a level 10
creepiness factor
there's also different residents that
say they're female residents that want
to remain anonymous
that have have said that a hotel
employees including maintenance members
have been known
to take the master hotel key and enter
rooms of women that were staying there
alone and have sexually assaulted and
raped women
there and people have stayed quiet
because um a lot of people that were
staying there like they were either
you know it's a weird part of town so
they were kind of like hiding from
places they didn't want to be found so
they didn't
say anything a lot of residents were
scared of losing their homes
so but it was like a known fact around
the building that that was happening
i told you whoever is behind this hotel
is responsible for someone in the hotel
yeah but then there's too many
coincidences with that movie
right so um the the
also in 2015 the detective one of the
detectives that was working on the case
disclosed that there was actually a
second video that they never showed the
public
oh is it the one you got no oh it's a
there's another one
yeah of her entering the hotel with two
men with her
and one of the men gives her a box and
that's all that's
told i bet she gave him some box i'm
kidding maybe i shouldn't have done that
i'm sorry
please forgive me i gave her permission
it's okay
she has a patch she's a pass just for
running around passes just please help
me out here
i'm gonna show you one more video
because people
were uh one youtuber named cody frye
pointed out that it seems to be
sped up the i mean it seems to be slowed
down the footage that they released
so he actually sped it up and it looks
like much more natural movements
oh so this is the one that he thinks is
a natural time
he thinks the hotel slowed it down yeah
to make her
look a little bit more crazy and like
her movement
she still looks she does but she looks a
little bit more playful
rather than slow yeah i still feel like
it looks like she's playing with a
little kid
yeah she kind of smiles or she looks
like if there happens to be like a kid
that's like
staying in the hotel annoyed that this
hotel didn't have
other cctv like cameras or they didn't
release it
yeah like what the what yeah she does
look like she's
she's being kind of playful and there's
uh there's a whole video if you're
interested there's a video interviewing
um a body language expert
and she says that all during this part
it seems like she's expecting somebody
or she's
kind of like in a flirtatious mood and
she's even doing her hair there's a
mirror right here
and she's reaching up and she's like i
think she's doing her hair or messing
with her hair right here
but everything's like kind of natural
she's kind of like in a good mood
whereas here
she looks like drunk or like on
something right
but it's not elevator like she's still
doing some weird [ __ ] though
the body language expert believes that
because she accidentally pressed a
button here that
held the hotel door she did it again
because she's still waiting for that
person
and she's kind of she does have her she
is bipolar but she's kind of like
going over what she might say to this
person she's like kind of
i should do that with her hand right
she's kind of going over like first i'm
going to say this and then i'm going to
say this yeah
oh and that'd be so exciting they'll
like that this is what the body language
expert says
i don't feel like terrified i don't feel
like bipolar people are like
that though well
i don't know the the video that i
watched with this particular expert says
she's worked a lot
in on cases with people that have mental
disorders and so
specifically with bipolar yeah but um
you know i didn't research like exactly
what
pieces she's worked on she's just worked
on the time stamp thing does freak me
out because it looks like the hotel
superimposed over it so that they could
hide the editing of the timing
somehow we've lost seconds but they can
still kind of see through it
you can see where the minute hands and
second hands are
and then they show like this you know
you saw the rest a lot of people are
saying that they only released that
video to make her look
yeah because there's no other footage of
her looking normal throughout the rest
of the hotel
santiago is in on that you don't need
you don't like
santiago no i would say he's the one
that's a fan of the movie another
another inconsistency is there were
independent coroners that didn't really
buy the whole
uh original autopsy story that there was
no
damage done to her body there was no
like there were no bruises or anything
and
um and so they did independent autopsies
and
they found not only was there not only
did the coroner's office not test for a
date rape
drugs um and didn't test do it do a rape
kit or anything like that
uh there also wasn't any water in her
lungs and she was found
what oh up instead of face down like
most people that drown
yeah are found face down she was just
like dead and then thrown in there
yeah so she didn't actually take in any
water yeah they say it's much more
likely
that somebody suffocated her and then
put her body
in there and threw her clothes in which
makes a lot more sense okay well then i
take it back that she did it herself
then
yeah that's that's where i kind of
turned to and also there were
the reports because originally they said
there were no there's no foul play
but then on the independent coroner's or
independent autopsy reports
um they noted that there were so there
was some anal
uh damage yeah and oh my god all these
things okay so like the american horror
story season like there's like little
monsters that do a lot of these things
and there was like a there was like a
monster that like anal rapes
do you remember that one yeah i remember
oh creepy creepy creepy and then 2017
the 9th circuit
actually revived the lawsuit for
a falsified autopsy because the chief
medical examiner that originally did
this autopsy
was sued in court and charged with
falsifying an autopsy on another autopsy
so he has faults falsifying an autism
they know who to call to get a fake
ass off talking yeah oh all of la is
is [ __ ] up like yeah if you have
enough money you can have
anything done so i think that's all of
the
things that i had to say about that that
i found about this um the guy that wrote
the book that investigative journalist
he also interviewed um one of who was it
the deputy coroner for this case and he
asked the detective
what he thinks happened and the
detective said that
he personally thinks she went on the
roof with an employee of the hotel
santiago i'm telling you but why
wouldn't they just like pin it on him
and throw him in jail that'd be a much
better story
he's so easy to like throw under the bus
why would they send him away
maybe the hotel owners don't want yet
another mark on their business and then
they're going to lose money
yeah they were doing that big hotel deal
you know
and who knows how much that was worth
and they didn't want it to be like
to ruin the deal this that there was
this murder or something happening
among the other 500 murders that were
there yeah i know like as
long as yeah there's 10 000 other ones
who cares about that one
i think they wanted to rebrand it as a
place for young people to stay
oh yeah definitely not you guys down to
stay at night
no no it's gonna be enough i'm like no
way you guys the energy i mean honestly
like if
if anybody wants to like riot in l.a
again can we just burn that place
i'm kidding i'm kidding don't sue me
hotel imagine that hotel is covered with
some protection of dark magic i know
like you throw
fire but it does nothing nothing it
won't burn down
it's like a portal to hell i mean there
has been a lot of satanists that have
done rituals and stayed there and
in the series they get stuck there
they're all dead and they're all stuck
there
yeah spoilers if you wanted to watch
that oh my god it's like
is that the hotel in california yeah oh
hotel california
we got eagles but you can't never leave
no
yeah they're not evil in that one though
they're just sad oh they're just
saddened
oh wait which one would be the hotel no
but they you don't know
they could be evil you think they are
they're singing about something maybe
you're just tricked into thinking that
it they're that it's nice it's fine
the old hotels are like the creepiest
like that's my favorite they really
are what i mean i don't like it but like
those are my favorite stories
oh okay like there's the old timey like
1920s
vibe with the hotels and the ghosts
isn't this the same hotel
that i don't know how true the story is
but i
remember reading something about this
one hotel
that was built by some mega rich
guy and i don't know what year like
1920s maybe even like late 1800s
or something like that and he would
build uh
he would build this hotel in a certain
way where it was kind of like a torture
chamber for all these victims and there
would be like secret passages
everyone knew about and there'd be like
special shoots
for bodies and so they could get dumped
and i
i heard that that was the hotel that was
based
around the uh what is it
the american horror story thank you i
think it's this one it's the hotel cecil
that's a different one i know
several years ago in vegas there was a
haunted house that was
built by eli roth um in vegas he did a
haunted house based off of that hotel
that you're talking about
so i think those are two different
hotels but yeah like the crazy guy that
would like do all this weird [ __ ] he had
all these like different like trap
ways to get around their hotel rooms he
was just like this crazy
serial killer yeah he was like mega rich
and he could get away with it because he
had the money to get away with it
maybe this is the same hotel i'm
wondering i don't know heard about that
it gets all mixed together
well i think that those two guys in that
video that was disclosed
years later i think one of them had
something to do with it
um and whether they were hotel workers
or possibly
handlers some yeah someone like very
important like an epstein
yeah like something like that like like
gina was saying earlier someone powerful
or someone powerful as kid or someone
related to them or like
something where they like knew they
could get away with stuff and maybe they
were watching her throughout the whole
time she was staying there they knew
she'd been separated to
a different room i also didn't hear
anything else from those roommates that
um that said she was she had odd
behavior there's no interviews with them
or anything
and i'm wondering if like maybe they
just made up that her roommates
complained about her to get her
into a private room because no one ever
like you'd think after this the
roommates would be like no you don't
understand guys she was acting crazy or
something like that
but they didn't ever speak again and
they probably got paid off too just like
santiago maybe
i don't know um but then yeah so maybe
there were handlers
and in the box i think they handed her
that outfit
i think they were like i think they were
obsessed with that movie and
they wanted it to be just like that i
wonder if her parents would recognize me
like she's never had that outfit she's
never had a skirt
no that's true there's just so so many
coincidences there where it's like
how is that not based on that movie yeah
maybe this is like some sick twisted
like fantasy they had over this movie
right and i think they just prayed on
the right
person who had a mental condition you
know mental health disorder
and she also was in a spirit of like
wanting to meet new people like very
eager to meet new people
and you know talking to everybody and
like kind of opening up
too much and so naive still exactly
it like showed her as being an easy
target what if they've
discovered her from her previous look
like
what if there's this underground network
of hotel workers who prey on people
and then they hit up those people and
like hey
i got one for you perfect it could be
yeah really but that doesn't explain the
the hotel address at the cemetery she's
buried i know
that stuff i don't even have an answer
for i'm like that's just
crazy no that's the bookstore's website
yeah
the last place she was seeing it's also
called the last bookstore it's
that's so they're in on it too how can
hotel in the owner
and then you know then if this was a
cover-up like
people in the lapd had to be paid off
but you know there's corruption there um
and in fact i think i was reading that
it was some members of the lapd who
who think that this case got corrupted
and they actually
went and got the independent autopsy so
there might be like some split
inside the lapd and that area has kind
of been known to like have a
relationship with the
lapd so you know there's a lot of
strange things there
powerful people are downtown in la
i don't know i don't like that it was so
recent i like all the scary stories to
be like from
really old 1950 and prior like there's
no way that that could
yeah but in this case it's like that
could have been yeah we were alive
during this
yeah super creepy i'm scared i yeah i
can't imagine like at 21 years old like
you don't know you're kind of you're
just so naive you're like i'm grown like
i'm just exploring i'm an adult
god if this was like my first trip out
being an adult and everything i would be
so pissed
yeah he was a ghost now yeah
ghost [ __ ] up guys i just got here i
didn't even get to see anything
i know who paid my bill i just think
it's so sad for like the family they
never get
any like justice from it it's like and
they have no power against these people
you know like there's nothing you can
really do and this was before like
petitions to go fund me and like you
know the the pressure of social media to
actually
take action on crimes like this so they
didn't really have that power behind
them either
and even what they did it seems like
whoever's behind this is way stronger
than they can ever deal with i think so
i mean there's definitely a resurgence
like that guy that wrote the book that
just recently came out
like a year or two ago and so um there's
people that are
very unsatisfied with the results of
this case and want it reopened
and that's why all this new evidence has
been coming out and but the only way for
it to get reopened
is if someone related to her reopens the
case so
it would have to be her family reopening
the case yeah they're probably too
scared too
i know yeah there's probably some or
yeah or they disclosed a deal
we know for sure that that was her body
i mean because if we're saying that
hotel guests were getting like
black stuff in their water how badly was
she decomposed the teeth would still be
there
so maybe they can do like dental records
dna
or any surgeries or metal things block
the pipe or something
i don't know i'm like what is this black
slate it could also be like
what if they falsified their reports of
the complaints
there was no telling how deep this went
to cover everything up yeah
so i'm filming that it's a cover-up now
because a lot of people
this first came out they were firmly on
the side of like she
had a manic episode and she slipped in
there yeah
but then all this new stuff came out and
people were like oh wait
if i was a murderer and i got footage of
a girl like playing like maybe there was
her neighbor had a kid with them or
something and she was like playing in
the hallway with the little kid
jumping in and out of the elevator and
then i'm like oh this footage is [ __ ]
perfect
yeah and then and then so now you have a
target a perfect target with a perfect
story and they look like she created
everything they could to cut out whoever
else was in the video
there's missing times there's a lot of
missing footage [ __ ]
it's unexplained and the lack of cameras
like when i used to work at a hotel my
my front desk people would literally be
able to tell which room i went to
every like in every room yeah so many
cameras
yeah i'm like how is there only just one
camera that we get to see
exactly she was there for two weeks
right before she died she was there from
january 26 to february first so oh oh
okay one week okay there wasn't any like
record of her checking out so shouldn't
they have like checked her bedroom yeah
where's her luggage
her stuff they should have reported
who's paying for the room oh right
i don't know if she was or her parents
were but
they didn't say but yeah this is why i'm
so scared of traveling on my own dude
yeah i don't want to go anywhere by
myself yeah excited i could do japan by
my own because even then it's like
traveling while woman sucks yeah
that's why when i was trying to do my
solo trip i'm like
it's a little scary it could have gotten
stolen oh that is like
least likely for me to get killed
because that would traffic me
i would traffic all of you guys thank
you you guys are traffickable yeah
i got it i would make it i was too old
to be trapped
you ladies would make me some goddamn
money okay thank you yeah yeah it's
scary as [ __ ]
i i really wouldn't like but i think
back then i probably would like at 21
i'm like oh that sounds fun
you know yeah dude i almost went to new
york by myself and i was 22
i think yeah it just sounds fun it's
like oh it's an adventure
i'm an adult now then later you're like
you you've
learned too much of what happens in the
world yeah exactly especially going to
these creepy [ __ ]
seedy hotels like hotel cecil or
whatever the [ __ ]
never i will never stay in a hotel like
that you'll be curious with the reviews
i'm kind of curious to look up that
hotel what it looks like now i don't
know upgrade it i want to go drive by it
you can go to the lobby we're gonna get
spotted
targeted honestly i don't want to go
inside yeah i feel like once you cross
that door
you go inside it you're like planted
with like some negative energy yeah
i'm good after hundreds of people dying
in there no
thanks for getting possessed everywhere
like i know
but by taking their own lives there's so
much i think actually in vegas a lot of
people suicide in vegas yeah
yeah like we could have there's probably
some really good [ __ ] murder mystery
[ __ ] [ __ ] in vegas definitely no
isn't there some statistic about like
there's like this much probability that
you have stayed
in a in a room in vegas after
someone has just died like right before
yeah i think it's probably a
pretty pretty high percentage yeah
probably like a 10 to 20
percentage if you've been there more
than 10 times there's that hollywood
hotel where my my
my hair stylist on the bottom floor he
used to uh so he had a hairstylist or
i'm sorry a salon on the bottom floor
it's like an
old hotel on melrose um
and do you know that that that that
that medium guy that speaks to the dead
or whatever
that i told you guys about the one that
did my reading and i cried one time he
was doing a reading on the bottom floor
where the salon is and
um he was doing a reading for this
person he's like and all of a sudden
he's like he stopped talking he was
do you know a woman that passed away and
then the one he was reading for his
customer was like no i don't have any
women that passed away in my family
he goes there's this woman standing here
she won't let go of her throat like she
she can't speak but she keeps holding
her throat and his client was like
no i don't know anyone and then all of a
sudden the hotel owner comes downstairs
to the salon who's like hey
just want to give you guys a heads up
the cops are coming we found a woman
hanging
right above like on the floor above you
whoa so her spirit was there
whoa yeah hollywood is i mean la is
haunted as [ __ ]
ellie's so haunted that's my house ever
again that's why honestly like my hotel
that i mean my hotel
my apartment complex that i'm in now is
like pretty old and i feel like it's
it's
it's in um an area where a lot of child
actors were in and
there were some people on our
neighborhood app that were like posting
um stories
of like some pedogate [ __ ] from like
from the apartment complex that i live
in
i'm moving out now i'm moving to another
city in a brand new
completely brand new constructed
building because i don't want the energy
of that
that's crazy don't stay in old places in
la it's great
places hollywood things hello a lot of
hollywood actors or anything
are we now this is not a hollywood
person this is not a hollywood
city yeah culver city is close enough
it's so funny because it makes me think
like the ghosts are like oh
no they're like i want to be here not
culver city the floor is on cricket
all right guys well i hope you enjoyed
it episode
of murder mystery mood if you like this
let us know in the comments if you would
like to see more
we were kind of just thinking it's like
halloween time like we should yeah we're
going to do
stuff but if you like hearing the
stories if you like
this format let us know maybe we'll do
some more and
make sure you leave your theories down
below tell us what you think
yeah well tell me yeah if you found a
better like website with all the better
theories let us know
yeah i'm invested no if you made this
drink and if you like it as much as that
oh yeah
yeah i like it but then i started
feeling that like the blackberries were
kind of like her body
um all right
well i did pick these drinks for a
reason yeah you made it look like bloody
no i didn't it's a good call good it's
like blackberry black sludgy water
exactly so i like it i'm
oh my god oh my gosh all right i'll see
you guys next week
[Music]